vestida de amarillo y llena de emoción
Bienvenidos a Dinamarca los aficionados
del ciclismo se reunieron en copenhague
el viernes para presenciar el inicio del
Tour de Francia 2022 para los lugareños
ver el evento era una obviedad y muchos
Llegaron temprano para conseguir un
lugar en la ruta esto Solo ocurre una
vez así que tenía que estar aquí mi
mujer me llamó loco pero no me importa
es un día histórico Es la primera vez
que algo así llega a copenhague así que
todo el mundo está emocionado y yo vivo
cerca Así que pensé en llegar temprano y
el resto de la familia vendrá más tarde
los aficionados franceses también
acudieron en masa viajando hacia el
norte específicamente para el evento o
incluso cambiando los planes de viaje
para presenciar el gran de paz estamos
haciendo un viaje en carro por Europa
para llegar a copenhague hoy hemos
tenido que apurarnos un poco nos dijimos
que esto no nos lo podíamos perder
Es la primera vez que viajamos al
extranjero para verlo y vemos que hay
muy buen ambiente
después de la escénica prueba
contrarreloj del viernes en copenhague
los 176 corredores completarán otras dos
etapas en Dinamarca incluyendo el cruce
del puente del Gran cinturón que une las
islas de Zelanda y fúnebren el pelotón
se trasladará a Francia el lunes